what did you save - Andy to get kicked
out of camp I was home from school and I
was watching you there's helicopters
like can you take me to that day please
this was during training camp and this
particular date it was the receiver's
day to sign autographs
so I I had a growing issue at the time
so I just felt like let me use this time
to go get myself healthier in the
training room we had a bit of a
disagreement and it was like right in
the doorway of where you know people
were players and coaches so yeah and I
think some other people just you know
listen to the conversation so you know
he felt like I was showing him up and
coach said go home in the meantime he
said keep yourself in shape why yet I'm
in the house maybe 2025 minutes I
started hearing helicopters or whatever
but I didn't think much of it somebody
came and knocked at the door and now I
looked through the blinds news trucks
were all out in my yard
the helicopters and everybody was around
my house I just tried to have fun with
it saw my ab bench took it outside I was
you know entertaining the the reporters
and I was working out at the same time
little did anybody know I had an
earpiece on I called my publicist at the
time she was listening to every question
that was being asked of me and so she
basically just told me kind of what to
say what not to say and so I just makes
that no comment or whatever so did you
go back and you're like Andy
I was keeping myself in shape well yeah
I mean at some point he kind of figured
that out